oh my God I love you thank you you look
so great thank you you too you're all
glowy thank you congratulations on all
the things happening in your life right
now you're do you're just
killing killing it I last time we talk
it's Christmas time last time we talked
about Christmas Villages like we
decorated have you decorated this year
I'm halfway up I my house was under
renovation so everything was in storage
and they pulled it down and I started
putting my tree together and I was like
something's missing and my team thinks
I'm crazy because I have a lot of
villages a lot of houses and I'm like
something's missing and she was like
you're right my assistant had everything
pulled down and I was like I told you
the house was missing there I know my
Village me too what did you add this
year so my son decided because we have
New York we have we have Islands we have
New York and Brooklyn W yeah we have a
Brooklyn I was like okay I was like
maybe next year we'll add Jersey I don't
know what we're doing but he they're all
the Charles Dickens it's still the
department you know it's still that old
school thing but he but he calls them my
seven-year-old son was like oh no that's
Brooklyn I was like okay I didn't even
know you knew that yet like I didn't
even know you like what like it was but
yeah it's all set it's not we're not
final it's not final this week is
actually I'm putting the final when I
get back that's when it's all together
I'm adding a road I added a carousel a
beautiful Carousel don't I added a ice
skate ring we have an ice skating ring
yeah do you have the water fountain
girl what no we don't have a water
fountain I have a water fountain I don't
have a water fountain and I don't a
carousel I have a police station and a
fire station we have Poli station fire
St does the car come in and out like
this shut
up I'm getting need picture um okay so
what about your childhood what's like a
favorite Christmas memory oh favorite
Christmas memory I remember one year
because of me it was my bright idea I'm
the creative in the family and I put
together I was was like let's have a
family um um talent show yes and so I
thought I was going to win because you
know I'm the talent of the family and I
sang um Angel by um uh
Ang true blank thanks and then my uncles
came in and they blew the roof off the
house with um the Temptation song Oh
which one um it's Merry Christmas Happy
cuz I have an uncle with the why can't I
think of songs today say that again
Silent Night yes Silent Night no one's
ever heard of it no right that's a it's
a new it's a new song apparently so they
they kic they killed it they totally
stole the show and it's literally we
talk about it to this day I mean this
was when I was 12 I'm 53 we're still
talking about this moment wait I totally
thought you meant you did this as an
adult and you were like and you were
like I wanted everyone to do a talent
show cuz I was going to win and I was
like I was just picturing you at like 35
just like I've got my Anita Baker okay I
love it it's even it would have been
better if you would have been 35 so
what's one of your favorite Christmas
Memories with your son oh God he's older
now but like no he's grown now but I
love when they're little bits yeah you
know when they're little little little
because but you know that's my B he's so
grown now and that was I produced that
play on Broadway
J yeah that's so awesome to see his mama
killing it yeah he was so proud he
really was proud it is I have the young
age still so it is kind of still fun
because you know it's you know I think
we have more fun than they do like
putting the toys together the night
before but my son was funny he liked
what he liked so he would pick like two
or three things I swear I think I picked
the wrong baby up at the hospital but he
would pick like four toys and that's all
he wanted and I would buy him like 12
thinking he wants this he wants this
this is me with my children did he he
hurt my feelings because I would watch
him open the gifts and he would be
like and he would get those four gifts
that he asked for grab those up and go
in his room and all the other stuff I
bought is just sitting outside and I can
be this I can be this my kids don't even
open the
mall there's not that many like you know
what I'm saying they will literally open
once they find something they like they
just go play with and I'm like I'm sorry
I spend a lot of time doing this exactly
yes like these kids there's so
privileged I'm like what yeah they do
not know what it's like Anyway let's and
we worked hard for that but whatever
that was a look at her new movie The
Color
Purple that is an intense I was telling
her that I was like my thighs hurt from
watching this clip like like you're on
that table it looks fun like sometimes
when you have alcohol in here you don't
know until the next day but when you
don't have alcohol in ear it feels like
you're snowboarding yeah your thighs
burn no everything was burning yeah and
what you did not see is that I was I had
to ice my my knees in between every take
how many takes how many times they U
listen Oprah has seen all of the footage
from every angle and she counted she
said I climbed up on that table 88
times but your adrenaline goals you know
I wasn't counting I don't I don't think
so 88 times no and I don't have mag the
stallion these and so I'm climbing up
there and I'm dropping it low
child
I I was like woo that right there in the
heels by the way yeah they were
character shoes though they were
character who cares they're not flat
they're not flat you're absolutely right
yeah no it's a lot of work what was it
like for you like I can't imagine seeing
this as a kid and then now you're in it
right like how this I never imagined
myself in it I never I just remember
seeing the movie in 1985 I was 15 and I
had been um that's when I the the acting
bug awakened in me and I was like I
think I want to do that and I remember
going to the theater and saying all
those black faces and I saw me yeah that
allowed me to dream that allowed me to
go hey I I can do that and so shortly
after that I started really getting
serious about acting and then when I got
into college I read the book and I was
like yeah so I mean you know Alice
Walker did a great thing this is this is
like one of the
Cornerstone pieces of literature of
American culture like you know everybody
knows this movie white black it doesn't
matter it transcends race color religion
you know it's it's it is and everybody
can really see themselves in some of
these characters and what I love about
it is with this film we're going to be
breaking generational curses you know
healing families um hopefully yeah
because a lot of us were healed doing
this film you know um you think you got
over some things and here you are faced
with a character that has you have to
kind of take the band off bandaid off of
something you thought that healed and
yeah that art can be really healing you
know it really can did you dive into the
character did you relate at all I you
know I did you know because she was
literally The Cookie of the 1920s yeah I
know no literally she got off the
plantation and was like I'm going to
make something of myself you got to
remember this this film take this movie
take the book opens up it's the first
generation of freed slaves so a lot of
slaves was like well we free but where
are we going yeah so they were still
sharecropping and minding you know the
the the land that they were living on
this one decided I'm going to break free
and I'm going to make something of
myself and so she was like a change
maker every time she came on the scene
she lifted this she lifted it and
everybody I had a journalist say she's
almost like an alien that comes down
from out of space and that's how the
town treats her is like a big deal when
sh Avery comes to town because um the
people that she left behind didn't have
dreams or if they did they were deferred
you know and she didn't allow her dreams
to be deferred yeah she was afraid the
people were afraid to dream that big
exactly so she she was the dreamer you
know and she came back and I feel like
this is you I feel like you're that
person too every time I run into you
you're such a light like every time you
come out yeah you are that person though
when you enter a room like it couldn't
have been cast more perfectly thank you
yeah when it comes to like talking about
Injustice or racism like things like
that like I have friends like they have
to talk to their kids differently than I
had to have a talk with my kids did you
feel that with your boy growing up even
now at 30 yeah oh even to this day I
mean I think any black mother
grandmother uh niece auntie we worry
about our black men we worry about if
they leave the house will they come back
um if you this just something that lives
in in our subconscious it's it's just
there we carry it well but it's always
there especially when you're triggered
by something on the news or you're
scrolling you know Instagram and some
some kid has been unjustly arrested or
shot or something it sends a shock wave
not only through you but through the
entire Community because we feel it we
feel it as one unit am I lying no no and
and also like it even as a I mean I
can't imagine the next step of that but
even as a parent you always worry anyway
there's there's that fear anyway you
want them to like fly you want him to
you wanted to do stuff but like yeah I'm
afraid of people sometimes outside my
house yeah exactly it's just that extra
layer of will he be protected by the law
yeah you know yeah so man well it's
tough but you know has y y'all are
sitting there though in that and with
that play bill and it's your show and
you're doing it I just love like to show
him like what a successful boss mom
looks like like hold it down and like I
know but that's like cuz you've also set
the bar for whatever relationships he's
going to have in the future you know
what I'm saying that's I don't think we
realize that until you become a parent
you're like oh man we're setting the bar
for our kids are watching us I want to
show them what love looks like what
success looks like what happiness looks
like like you're doing such a great job
thank you so much it's so
cool well anyway I know that you like
games I know that you're competitive I'm
competitive so I feel like we should
play a Christmas game okay okay well
we've got a Christmas game coming up
next all the color purples in theaters
starting Christmas day will be right
[Music]
[Applause]
back thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home